[Musique]
quand jean-pierre pernaut n'est pas à la
télévision ils se regardent à la
télévision oh non par coquetterie mais
tout simplement pour faire plaisir à
julia tullia c'est sa petite fille jean
pierre pernaut on peut le dire sans
méchanceté c'est vraiment gentil vedette
du journal de 13 heures
on a l'impression que vous êtes le père
tranquille à tf1 c'est à dire que passer
inaperçu vous êtes bien gentil
un peu anonyme d'un oui oui parce que
j'essaie d'abord de faire mon métier et
je pense qu'il faut il faut être anonyme
pour faire ce métier parce que
quand on parle à la télévision ce n'est
pas un journaliste qui parle c'est
quelqu'un qui donne une information et
l'essentiel ce n'est pas le journaliste
l'essentiel c'est l'information qu'il
donne
en vrai picard qui est damien vernon
n'aime pas tellement parler de lui et
encore moins qu'on parle de lui son
souhait travailler travailler et encore
travailler
le but que j'ai ça n'est pas de
de passer devant les autres ou derrière
les autres le but que j'essaie de faire
mon métier est actuellement on donne la
possibilité de le faire et si j'en suis
très heureux c'est tout c'est pas
c'est pas un manque d'ambition
non il faut avoir de l'ambition
l'ambition je crois que le principal
dans ce dans ce travail c'est de bien
faire son boulot c'est de bien informer
les gens et de se dire après un journal
eh bien on à informer les gens sur
l'essentiel
en fait ce père tranquille de la
formation télévisés ne rêve que d'une
chose amiens amiens et sa cathédrale
gothique participe par son père amiens
c'est toute sa jeunesse à bien c'est
aussi le hockey sur gazon qu'ils
pratiquent encore de temps à autre avec
l'équipe du stade français a parlé
[Applaudissements]
le cas sur gazon ça représente toute ma
jeunesse j'ai joué dès l'âge de 10 ans
jusqu'à
23 ans à peu près donc ça fait 13 ans de
jeu et ça représente pour moi des
voyages des amis que j'ai gardé ça
représente vraiment énormément de choses
j'essaie le plus souvent possible de me
replonger dans le bain de bloquer avec
mes anciens copains qui sont toujours
d'ailleurs
[Musique]